bonjour c'est philippe katerine pour
brut je me suis fait opérer du coeur
quand j'avais 8 ans donc c'était une
opération à coeur ouvert dans 76 donc
sans cette opération va choix décédées
depuis longtemps sera pas là vous parlez
donc
mon coeur il y avait un trop de temps
qu'ils ont rempli avec une peau de
cochon et ils ont marché sur une machine
et ça s'est arrêté 17 minutes mais
c'était prévu que ça s'arrête puis après
ils l'ont remis dans le corps et puis
c'est reparti donc ça on peut dire quand
même je suis obligé de dire c'était
quand même ça a changé ma vie parce que
j'ai juge des choses de la mort g pas si
j'avais des hallucinations quoi mais
j'ai vu des choses à la fois terrible et
mareyeuses donc ça on peut dire ça a
changé ma vie ça quand même
c'est sûr c'était quand même la deuxième
les sens je voulais tu n'es j'ai vu des
gens faire l'amour à j'avais huit ans
j'avais jamais vu ça je sais pas c'était
vrai ou pas mais
il y avait quelque chose de
d'un mirage donc la chanson est parti
sur cette ces deux notes jana et puis
après j'ai déroulé le fil c'était un
dimanche soir je me retrouve bien
évidemment quand une chanson à
à les partager parce que c'était chanter
dans les mariages ou dans les ca passait
dans les boîtes où les boums donc
évidemment ça fait tout drôle
c'est une chance inouïe de connaître ça
bien sûr d'avoir une chanson qui qui est
acquis dont pilsen king qui joue avec la
relation entre les gens c'est un rôle
social et une chanson dans cette chanson
gurria la frustration je coupe le
changeront mais le son est celui qui
coupe le son qu'il remet le son est
victime canda lynchage collectif
donc évidemment
une chanson très cruel de du groupe à
l'individu donc c'était intéressant ce
soit cette chanson qui tout d'un coup
est de les coupes sur la cruauté ces
gens sont sous aussi sur sur la clause
et j'ai constaté tout plus longtemps
j'avais jamais été
contrôlé dans le métro dans la rue une
constatation que je fais quand j'ai
presque 50 ans donc sa remontée donc ça
m'a fait réfléchir et j'en ai parlé à
d'autres blonde que moi et il se trouve
qu'ils sont reçus retrouve un petit peu
dans cette situation qui est pas la plus
merdique évidemment un mais qui
vous montre
même le
le privilège que vous vivez un
finalement qui a toujours existé
[Musique]
là on est en 81
un oeuf peut-être ou 90 c'était un 4000
francs à l'époque en euros je n'aime pas
combien
c'est ce que monstrueusement cher pour
moi mais enfin j'ai travaillé à une
usine de poulet et heureusement
j'habitais chez mes parents j'étais
revenue chez mes parents j'avais réussi
à économiser pour m'acheter ce fameux 4
pistes qui avec ça j'ai fait mes
premières chansons personnelles à ma
façon
puisque vous avez un 4 pistes dans votre
chambre personne et sur votre épaule au
dessus de votre épreuve pour vous dire
maintenant c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait
tout je vais faire ma façon de premières
chansons quand j'ai reçu le césar jeu
très heureux bien sûr qu'on me dise de
enfin qu'on apprécie voilà ce que femme
je prie sur tous ce césar pour l'équipe
parce que c'était un tel fils avec de
tels acteurs que j'avais
un peu honte d'eux
d'être le seul à recevoir le césar
vraiment ce que n'importe quoi
[Musique]